we're going to begin of course with
uvaldi this morning we've got a lot of
urgent new questions emerging about the
response to that horrific school
shooting in uvalde texas new details
from officials contradict their initial
description of what happened for example
they now say that police did not
confront the shooter on his way into
robb elementary school
janet chamleon is in uvalde with more on
this story janet good morning to you the
more we hear the worst this gets
good morning gail indeed cbs news has
talked to several law enforcement
sources they are not connected to the
case but they are raising concern about
the response by police here that the
police waited for a specialized team
before confronting the shooter they say
that is not the way active shooter
response is taught in most police
departments and this morning it's
raising questions here in the community
this morning police are searching for
the 18 year old killer's motive while
new details reveal a timeline that
leaves many wondering what took law
enforcement so long to stop the carnage
authorities say the 911 at 11 30 a.m
tuesday when the gunman's grandmother
reported he shot her
this video shows him approaching the
school
by 11 40 police say he entered the
building through an unlocked door
after initially saying he confronted a
security officer police now say that was
inaccurate no officer was present the
gunman then walked down a hallway and
into the two connected classrooms we
would shoot and kill 19 children and two
teachers
four minutes later
local police departments are inside
making entry
they hear gunfire they take rounds they
move back
get cover but we have officers calling
for additional resources
everybody that's in the area the officer
injured by bullets didn't go in further
instead calling for backup containing
the shooter to those adjoined rooms
the shooter was armed with a
semi-automatic long rifle a law
enforcement source telling cbs news he
was carrying 210 rounds of ammunition
the equivalent to what an average u.s
soldier carries into basic combat he had
450 additional rounds in a backpack but
dropped it as the carnage unfolded
social media videos show frantic parents
arriving outside held back begging law
enforcement to intervene during this
time that they're making those calls
to bring in help they're also evacuating
personnel
students teachers there's a lot going on
he came in and he crouched a little bit
and he said it's time to die this
nine-year-old boy hid as the shooter
entered the classroom he was one of the
fourth graders who survived many of his
classmates did not the cop said help if
you need help
and then
they got
one of the persons and my class said
help
the guy overheard and he he came in and
shot her
and then the cops barged in into that
classroom sources tell cbs news border
patrol tactical teams arrived at the
school just before noon and by the time
agents breached the room with a shield
to take the shooter out he'd been there
for an hour or more
they said they rushed in and like and
all that like we didn't see that
with a newly revealed timeline comes
criticism authorities didn't move
quickly enough javier cazares was among
the hysterical parents outside the
school his daughter jackie died i
honestly think that it
could have been
a lot more could have been prevented
than prepared
the school security budget had been
doubled since 2018 according to public
documents to comply with new state
regulations following another school
shooting in santa fe texas and the
uvalde police department and the school
district here had extensive policies in
place to prevent or mitigate school
shootings including having its own
police force to monitor the schools in a
policy of locking the doors of the
schools today parents and families here
are starting an unimaginable task
starting to plan their children's
funerals michelle
a lot more questions and i'm sure
demands for more answers janet thank you